what up reject nation's strongest
avengers have from new rockstars john
coygendro who by the way i know i
mentioned this last video koi's comic
corner is a segment that we are starting
up here on the channel video's supposed
to be out last weekend but uh it took me
longer to edit than i than i anticipated
but it'll be out this week i promise
my brevity i promise coy it'll be out
it'll be a comic expert here to help
break down the thor trailer right after
the reaction guys if you can leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe click the notification
bell to get notified when koi's comment
corner is up here on the channel and
lastly this video is sponsored by better
health a company that we are very
excited to partner with because all
three of us are therapy people
like all those other people who don't do
real therapy we know therapy up in here
mentally
therapy taught us to be this way about
other people and it's your brain
brain idiot more on that after the
reaction but yeah let's watch this
trailer
[Music]
kids get to popcorn out let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odinson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
[Music]
for the 500th time thor set off on a new
journey nice well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
whoa
oh [ __ ] son god where are you next
girlfriend
what's the family three four years
eight years seven months and six days
changing busy sensing
[Music]
she looks great man the only ones who
[Music]
god is themselves
[Applause]
impressive what you did back there
yeah
damn she's my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
zeus
[Music]
worth fighting for
wow
oh give me that monochrome all day
let's see who you are i take off your
disguise
you flick too hard damn it
eventually great
oh wow that is so easy-tastic what a
stunning second hearing christian bale's
american voice oh you know they're gonna
say
like sword like oh that looks yeah the
inverter looks amazing yeah dude that
was so freaking epic i think we all
loved it look koi has to get it you guys
go 30 seconds
we should get to you first okay
so really quick we're from better help
and then we'll get to koi's breakdown
thank you better help so in honor of may
being mental health awareness month
today's video is sponsored by the folks
at betterhelp.com the goal of this month
is to raise awareness about mental
health and as two people have been in
talk therapy couples counseling john
individual talk therapy for the better
part of a decade this is actually a
topic that we take pretty seriously and
the month is also about fighting stigma
and providing support to anybody who
might be struggling with their own
experience so through better helping
gain access to customized online therapy
that includes video phone and even live
chat sessions with one other 20 000
therapists you don't even have to see
anyone on camera if you really don't
want to and while traditional offline
therapy is great it can also be pretty
expensive and better help is not only
affordable but they also offer financial
aid and accept hsa benefits part of how
it works is you'll fill out a
questionnaire upon signing up so
betterhelp can assess your special needs
and match you with your first therapist
within 48 hours you can schedule secure
sessions with your therapist and
exchange unlimited messages with
complete confidentiality so this mental
health month if you or someone you know
is struggling please share with them
better help and feel free to use our
special link betterhelp.com real rejects
to save yourself 10 on your first month
that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
real rejects take care of yourselves
this month guys and the rest of the
months while you're at it every month
every month as every day as much as you
can
koi get to it okay so there is almost
definitely multiple thor's here i think
it almost confirms a lot of the rumors i
think that gore might actually be
systematically taking out thor's in
multiple universes we're living in this
multiversal age and all gods must die is
so iconic from the comic books it looks
like he is able to manipulate reality in
at least the black and white sense which
is very much from the asadra beast art
from the jason aaron run of the thor
comic books now i do think we're gonna
see the necro sword invert time i think
the necro sword is gonna cause a bit of
a reality manipulation which i think is
gonna allow him to take out gods with
whatever power set he has now i do think
we're gonna see a blend of greek
mythology north mythology all of these
things mixing with the mcu and that
would be a fun way to tie in different
mythos in the different universes while
we can play with the universe eight 833
or 616 or whatever universe we got we
also have the idea to play with these
different mythologies so i think we're
not only getting that but i think that
might be why it's so important we have
jane foster as the mighty thor in our
universe anchoring us to the mjolnir of
our universe with a god that is unique
to our space i think there are multiple
odin sons but i think there is only one
mighty thor and i think that's why it's
going to be really essential to tell
this story this way i also think we're
going to see a lot of really interesting
hijinks with a lot of mythical
characters like the goats i think we're
going to see a lot of stuff with the
guardians of the galaxy being confused
about the multiverse i think they're
going to be a bit of our eye line to
understand that there are multiple
thor's and most of all i think all of
this is going to be very approachable
through the guys of 80 sexy hemsworth
yeah definitely gore the god butcher to
me is a character that simplicity is his
strength i think a lot of people are
upset that he looks like an action
figure that looks like christian male i
think that's the power of this character
he's a guy that is pale nondescript and
has a necro sword and has billowing
white robes what is terrifying is the
performance what is terrifying is what
he's capable of what is terrifying is
that this is a person that simplicity
allows them to be kind of undermined
like you don't expect a lot from a guy
that looks like christian male when
you're in a world of colorful titans
it's not a coincidence that this is the
most colorful marvel film to date and
you've got a character that takes away
the very essence of color you've got a
character that takes away the very
essence of life a character who
literally wants nothing but destruction
which is why i think tyke has been
saying this might be one of the greatest
marvel villains to date i think his lack
of colorful flavor his lack of
versatility the fact that he's the
emperor palpatine of this whole world
the fact that he has one goal he's not
nuanced like thanos he's not like
killmonger when you identify with them
he all gods must die really quick though
this is all a teaser for how uh koi's
coming
so it's easy
so this guy you know with gord of the
god butcher's background involving null
symbiote and all yes i know we have the
teaser for the symbiote being left
behind in uh you know no way home
however this is a completely different
category you're dealing with all black
you're dealing with the very origins of
symbiote do you think we will actually
have that included in here or they will
just use the aesthetic design do you
think they will actually go to the
history of that you think we'll explore
the true origins of it i think a lot of
the strength of the marvel cinematic
universe is that they retroactively
allow whatever they want to i guarantee
you they plant seeds here that they can
choose or choose not to retroactively
turn into a symbiote so i think the
necrosword is going to be very much
slithery i think it's gonna be very much
uh leaned into that null might be the
cause of it and then if they choose in
however many years tom holland wants to
come back for and however they go from
that then they could make this a thing
when you look at the 10-year plan of
kevin feige not only is the strength of
the fact that he looks ahead he also
looks in the past he also goes hey let's
make thor dark world very relevant due
to end game let's do all these things so
i guarantee when they look at something
like null you have the seeds planted
because this is all donnie kate's joint
donnie kate's an incredible writer
writing hulk right now writing thor
right now all of those things are going
to establish a world that they can pick
and choose from with the benefit of
hindsight now imagine that everything he
did but you know just wait way more
editing and uh you know with more
inserts and graphics and stuff i just
wanted to make sure you guys know how
i'm just rushing to get this up right
here
buy some comments and most importantly
the same amount of input from both of
them yeah
all right koi look i know you got a jet
do you know what you see yourself on
here i mean i i figured out i'm like
hello
he's got tickets to some place and he's
running late already he's waiting for us
i wanted to stay this is awesome
i love you guys anybody like real
rejects
what do we do
uh
and yeah with this trailer what i
thought was really great about it was
getting more of the relationship with
natalie portman and chris hemsworth what
excites me about this is the last time
that we saw chris hemsworth and natalie
portman together the portrayal of thor
was so different much more brooding much
more serious we haven't had a chance to
see natalie portman interact with this
version of thor one who is a much more
of the comedic chris hemsworth style and
it looks like we're also going to get a
reinvention of natalie portman as jamie
foster to have more of her sense of
humor shine as well if you've ever seen
interviews with natalie portman or some
of the comedy she's done she is also
exquisite at comedy she really knows
comic timing very very well and in terms
of a lot of what koi was also riffing on
when it comes to gore the god butcher
you know like manipulating reality one
thing that i was thinking about was how
they brought it up again in avengers end
game due to the circumstances but in you
know thor the dark world she's infected
with the ether you know and that deals
with reality stone you know warping
reality so i wonder if in some way the
ether being in her is a big part of what
allowed them in reality for her to
manipulate itself into this situation
where she can now be the mighty thor i
think they would probably somehow hook
that in to here they might actually have
more chemistry chris hemsworth and
natalie portman here than they did in
the other thor movies simply because
they get to be more of themselves but
john we got other good things in here
you know we had zeus let's talk about
some stuff i just really like the film
styles on display here because if
there's one thing that i think uh you
know is sort of point of contention
about ragnarok for a lot of people is
that they did go full comedy they go
full garish and for some people that was
a bit too much and i think that this
does an interesting job and suggests a
tempering of that style and aesthetic
where yes you'll have the humor
obviously but gore by contrast looks
directly like an injection of intensity
and of monstrosity you look at the
design here it evokes things like the
orcs and the urukai from lord of the
rings as well as obviously the comic
book art that inspires gork i think that
that's an easy way without going too far
into like extreme content that you can
add something that's very chilling and
very hardcore to temper out some of the
stakes so that maybe this might appeal
further to the people who didn't like it
being so comedy oriented with tyka's
first outing with ragnarok so i feel
like this too represents an interesting
and an exciting growth for him on this
scale bringing in both his comedic chops
which we know he has in spades and then
also the more intense the more heavy
like goer looks like a
natural horror yeah it looks like an
earth-shaking villain and the i i am a
sucker for monochrome and the look of
those moments where they're out and it's
just floating debris and there's no
color really feel a like quintessential
comic book art and b like something
really fresh and interesting and
visually bold that the marvel cinematic
universe can now introduce i'm rooting
for this to be an expansion on taika's
film chops as well i'm glad you talked
about zeus zeus looks really fun and
great and i'm glad russell crowe is here
naked chris hemsworth always a plus i
bet that blur will not be there in the
movie yeah i bet there's a good new rock
stars trailer breakdown to check out but
guys thank you so much for being here we
got a rush to get the stuff for you all
we'll see you soon